what's up guys this is thomas dobasiolo
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast we're
here to talk about life problems drugs
accomplishments
and everything in between guys the
reason we're doing this intro i know
you're expecting
to see felipe right here the reason
we're doing this guys is because me and
him started talking
our guest today is felipe esparza you
may have seen him on
the winner of last comic standing you've
probably seen him at some of your
stand-up shows here in la he's just a
super funny person i'm a fan before we
ever thought about doing a podcast
so the second marty told me we booked
him i was extremely hyped guys i'm an
actual fan of this man
before anything and for those of you
binge watching on netflix hulu yes this
is felipe esparza he is on the show
superstore so i know a lot of you guys
are fans i have a lot of homies that
watch that
so you're gonna recognize this guy this
is just a i feel like these podcasts are
a dip
into the life that you might not know or
dip into the stories you might not have
heard so
guys today's really really it's for me
i'm i'm excited i'm a fan like i said so
this is going to be a fun episode for me
guys it's the weird intro we've never
done but we just started talking
sat down we just started talking no
intro no nothing and i forgot
so thank you guys so much for watching
let's get the episode started
[Music]
perfect all right might check my check
all right you roll these up
yes sir cool
no hatch in it just weed no worries
we went over p dogs and [ __ ] last
episode i know right
smoking cracking bloods
p dogs dipped in pcp see the pcps is the
one that got me
i didn't know about that and i took a
zip of it laced it to oregon
i got all [ __ ] up when i went to my
dad's house
i was trying to tell you sherm whatever
it is lovelies
is that what they're called to call them
lovely where my name my neighborhood
my neighborhood was like um the sherm
spot
if you want to call it a spot really
yeah
it's meth in my town well back in the
day you know it had his
it's um it changes you know
because my neighborhood started off as
thai bud bro like when there was no one
else to get
the good bud back in like 1980
81 82 84 85 86 87
if you want to get the best thai bud you
would go to my neighborhood they were
called
they should call it thai town really
they would call it thailand
because they will saw big long strips of
thai bud
that was just pure thai but like on a
stick yeah
thai stick yeah they're trying to taste
marijuana dry it out correct
yeah and it would just salad like that
on a stick like a kebab
so a lot of the guys in the neighborhood
they will write thailand on their
on their backs you know their tattoos
over the weed oh yeah and then
that that spot dried out and they were
selling um
i don't know what they were selling
because i stopped hanging around there
but in my neighborhood where i grew up
they were selling pcp
like kendall like dips man every
car would pass by and it was just how
much you want 20.
so just dipped a cigarette 20 pour 10
pour
whatever pour the full pour the wet
stick you know
i don't know how much that was but it
was it was a
a lot of business there i was i was like
in junior high that was what they asked
how old were you watching i was in
junior high
elementary school because i know that
section they were called
the chain what they were yeah the
projects
um pico gardens pico aliso
which is now demolished now it's um
i think it's just a number right yeah
man it's like
it's an ancient burial ground demolish
is in like all the buildings are so all
the buildings
got taken down in 97 96. is that or is
that not where they filmed some training
day or am i off
no they built they filmed blood and
blood out oh no [ __ ] where
is it the tree no it's not the tree
where um where um
where um come on i know that movie
whales i wanna know where i know
where my clothes mom live oh okay we got
the house at first she's doing her hair
and [ __ ]
yes that's the neighborhood that's
that's the projects and also in on
boulevard nights
both of our nights i'm going to watch
the world it's an old school movie um
the main guy's girlfriend
lived actually he she lived in the same
house
where my mom lived and blood and blood
out same house
damn they must have paid them for me use
that [ __ ] that's tight yeah like imagine
your ghetto at home was using two cholo
movies right like like some friday [ __ ]
did you see that they have a sign in the
yard or friday ten dollars to take a
picture or don't stop
although they're in chinatown too we
shot rush hour too
no [ __ ] yeah the rush hours team in the
chinese restaurant
damn see i'm not up on this man right
there on chinatown on western chinatown
there's a big unliterate um chris tucker
and um what was the other actor jackie
chan jackie chan
shot rush shaw we're here no [ __ ]
and the whole cell well the restaurant's
the same
yeah of course of course that's tight as
[ __ ] see i'm not up on this move i've
lived here for like six years probably
where are you from
uh you know where fresno is yeah i'm
from merced i'm like right by fresno
said what's up
oh you know yeah i performed there at
merced
but there's a coca-cola sign right
across the street
yeah the old-school theater it's a seven
up in coca-cola right yes
mexican restaurant damn that place is
scary as [ __ ]
damn the tower that's what perform i've
been to merced i've been to
when i first started off in standup i
did every farm town in california
bakersfield by celia porterville los
banos
and nobody ever hears about these this
is where i'm from that's where i'm from
yeah thanos is like the little version
of merced
yeah we're doing all theaters in all
these little towns yeah they had tiny
little theaters because
i i did the i didn't know this but when
i shot my
my special um translate this i shot in
san jose
and that's like that took a san jose
theater i think it should be owned by
fox
but that's where charlie chaplin's
movies used to play and
the three stooges were performing there
live afterwards they were done with
movies
but did i know that every t every farm
town
has a theater yeah we have bakersfield
has one the fox
then by celia has one too the fox
everybody has to do quinceanera
somewhere
probably man yeah no it's true you gotta
keep these uh migrant workers
entertained bro well
they want to stop working like i was
telling him it's nothing but like
my cousin type people and meth heads
that's pretty much it
and everybody talking like this you know
oh
you don't like the raiders that's how i
grew up because i'm a packer fan
these people will drop the n word in
spanish like it's part of their language
yeah because i remember i was working
with a promoter and um
somebody asked him um who's that
comedian and he said it right in front
of the other some other black guy
no no no it's not my yate roar he's
funny
he said like nothing bro like you know
like it's part of his language
and he didn't even care if there was a
black dude there who didn't know spanish
it's a farm town for sure for reals man
yeah portobello
is lumber is it really yeah they cut
lumber
and i know i know it because i know you
know by celia it's like the walnuts i
guess
i don't know man i just yeah he's
pulling deep local references and [ __ ]
i've been there
but like i said when i used to sell weed
and [ __ ] i would just drive by these
places
i never really stopped a [ __ ] stop in
delhi i never stopped that button willow
what the [ __ ] is that what is this
that's probably some obscure casino
willow is like the place where you look
at your you you're like
you're running out of gas coming from
san francisco and you're like you're not
even near
bakersfield yet and you go [ __ ] where do
i stop oh [ __ ] look
there's a gas station 56 miles away from
here
called butcher willow and right across
the street there's a
there's the um there's a um
in and out so either in and out and
that's it in a gas station and
get on the freeway and go back home
where is this at man because i drive a
lot it's stressing me out thinking about
trying to sell out a comedy show in that
town
uneasy i never saw last night i've never
been to buttonwell about the
the places where i've been to like are
merced by celia
those places people show up man there's
not much to do someone salinas
yeah yeah salinas yeah yeah that's way
up there yeah that's steve iceland
fresno clovis and [ __ ]
they show up man they get all dressed up
you know they're not like
hearing that label they wear tennis
shoes you know they they get really
dressed up man straight
dress pants like when like when a
comedian goes into town you know in
these towns like vaselia
the whole city makes money man not just
a comedian because they got to go buy
clothes
and go get a
i available this oh man we ran out of
beer
oh [ __ ] like i did a theater in by celeb
where they ran out of beer
at the theater and somebody did a beer
run to a 7-eleven and just bought beer
from there
and started studying at the theater [ __ ]
it it's a small town
yeah but celia is like a small town
where the promoter gets you know like he
knows how to
make money like like other sides around
unlike these um these carp these wooden
slats you just put in the middle of the
street you know the one you put
outside they had the menu on it oh yeah
yeah but instead of saying philippe
esparza
oh [ __ ] yeah fox theater he knows all
about
this promoter [ __ ] right here and no but
this dude takes it to the next level bro
like
like instead of hiring a bartender
he hires a bartender in school hey how
about you come over here
you could grade a student how well they
do smart i love that
okay and then he has budweiser sponsor
show so the part of the beer already
paid for so it's being sold
you've seen this bro i went to a comedy
show there where i was coming to the
comedy show and we watched a lot of
people and there were like
five blood weather tents already people
are drinking before the show
do you think it's worse when people are
shit-faced at the shows for me it's fine
you know people are happy when they're
drunk
people in my show don't get they don't
want to stab nobody bro
no no you're happy brother like they're
like over 34
you know okay they're established and if
you're there
21 years old you'll probably be [ __ ]
up your whole life and your dad made you
come with him
oh [ __ ] do you think the comic show yeah
man i think so
did i look at these faces like this guy
right here with his face
all tattooed he really wanted to come to
my show or they forced him
there probably was an intervention for
him to come to my shop i don't know you
gotta come laugh
nah but there are some fans that are my
fans but sometimes look at them he goes
they walk up to me i don't know who the
[ __ ] you were man but man
you may i'm your biggest fan now mm-hmm
got you
but that made me come yeah because
you've been experiencing this for how
long how long have you been doing comedy
i started doing stand-ups in in 1995 bro
oh wow oh damn but i got my first tv
credit in 96.
it's show time with greg geraldo nice
paul rodriguez a lot of comedians who
are not here no more
there all right there's a question i
want to ask i've asked a lot of people
yeah
where was the day that you were doing
comedy you're into it the day you went
home went
damn this is what i'm [ __ ] doing now
because like there's an excitement
you get when you [ __ ] venture into
something new when you kill it my first
time i went up on
stage at this coffee house right there
on i think um
fountain avenue it's called the fountain
theater now but before it was called the
natural fudge
because the owner and uh there were
hippies okay
so it was all vegan with the cherry and
stuff i didn't even know it was a
vegetarian stuff man
i just like darren it's just like crappy
and he's salt but there was like i'm not
mocking vegan food you know
now but some of the vegan food before
before monty's burgers you know yeah i
feel you pre-daily
real food daily you know we're talking
about just sandwiches with
that's what's good with grass in it you
know yeah wheat shot grass and [ __ ]
avocado toast yeah that type of stuff
man
i was not ready so that's the type of
stuff they had there
and i went up on stage man
i thought i killed you know you when
you're young you don't know what funny
is
you just know you're funny so i went up
there man i did my seven minutes
that i written down on paper i don't
even know what i
just went through it real fast i
couldn't make fun of some people there
because it was like
i started making fun of the audience
because it was a tough gig bro it was
like a
it was a punk comedy night
so and you're up to hair still or no pre
no hair brian
hair shorter than you bro i look like it
just came out of the american me set
oh [ __ ] this is 1995. this is 1996. yeah
i had short bald hair
buzz a big head so you started making
fun of [ __ ] in the audience yes
there was there was a guy that performed
before me
and he was like wearing a black suit a
black tie
he looked like men in black but then way
before men in black
and um he was funny and i had to follow
him
i said give it up for the last comedian
man i didn't know black people were army
shay oh [ __ ] he was the amish i went to
his house he had no electricity he had
no food
he had no television this guy is totally
off the grid
first show first show bro and everybody
laughed at that
and then i made fun of this other woman
because um she was kind of atheist and i
was like
catholic because she was she was
heckling the comedians bro
somebody out louder would you tell
someone who's not cr
if someone oh that guy's joke if someone
says
if an atheist needs this what do you
tell him
and that lady who yelled out you turned
the [ __ ] off
so i started making making fun of her
you know i said give it up for um
for um for ashley rose
rose sister get the [ __ ] out of here
she's the only talented rose you know
she just like the drugs
and she'll yell at people and everybody
laughed
so then i went to my material which was
not funny at all
i said a horrible jokes bro i said i'm i
said well i'm going to make a movie
right
i'll start be like paul rodriguez you
know and do the comparison thing between
mexican and white people
so i said they're not that many um
mexican movie
america movies here with uh mexicans
they know not even native movies man
but doing my own movie like latino
mohicans it's gonna be
about the last masking in l.a called
last of the mojados oh my god that was
your joke yeah rules i mean that's [ __ ]
it's
it's a joke it's cool yeah whatever yeah
it's cool and then i said that um i said
another joke about
um it was another joke that was not
funny but i thought that's not
funny i said it's embarrassing now i
think about any time i said um
i said what if um romeo and juliet was
in my neighborhood eh it'll be romeo all
cracked out
on the floor looking for crack yelling
up for julia
juliet julia throw down my lighter [ __ ]
[ __ ] you romeo i don't want to see you
again you [ __ ] crackhead
yo wait so what neighborhood this is
boyle heights you're comparing all this
to
yeah and then like people are not
laughing but
wait for real yeah so the next week bro
i brought i
invited invited like 15 of my friends
for audience members
nice so they they were like laughing and
juicing it up and just set it up
[ __ ] it well why do you think you
weren't funny no i i thought it was fun
you know you know just don't
you don't know man but um it must have
been funny but i don't remember hearing
no laughs
because i was talking about i was
talking real fast but you didn't have
your cadence yet or something no way
i was deadpan bro how was that like i
was talking i would
deliver all my jokes like comedians like
stephen wright and
and mitch hepburg oh very monetary
monotone so
still funny my job were like this
the last guy that was here the last guy
over here yes i think he was amish right
he was
a black amish guy i mean i mean he had
no car i mean he had no electricity
and they both started laughing i said
today i was shopping
lifting shopping lifting
yo but i get it yeah i mean it's
monotone if that's your thing and you
play to it but that's not you obviously
it's not you
yeah but the owner of the place his name
was johnny roberts
and he had a what was uh back then if
you guys don't know us
if you ever if you ever um have cable i
don't know if it still exists but if you
go to channel three
if you had local cable it's just like a
like uh um
communities community um channel
where anybody in the community could
have a show yeah yeah local access yeah
yeah as long as you i guess you don't
have to pay you have your own show
but you just have to commit to it to do
it your own show
so i would watch these shows there was a
show called colin's sleazy friends
and these two guys named colin and his
friend um
danny i don't know dan or i got a name
dino
danny it was carly and dino calling and
cd friends
they were just like you and i bro doing
a podcast except it was on local access
and he would interview pornos and at the
end bro you know what i mean
they start shaking them booze hello and
you could see a little bit of naked you
know
so that was like my thing before to
watch so his show was on
the guy i met johnny robert his show was
on i met him on tuesdays no
different guy okay but he had his show
at the same place so he said hey buddy
we're gonna do a comedy show live comedy
show um we want you to be in it you know
it pays 25 bucks so just come on down
here
tuesday nights so man i thought i made
it bro
i'm a first show i'm already gonna be on
[ __ ] television paying you
25 bucks and so i went there bro and
like there's an audience now
and i was on local access but i didn't
know local access i thought it was like
big time like comedy central or
something yeah
but i didn't know so tv though i know at
that how old were you
26 25 i thought it was the [ __ ] it's
still the [ __ ] though
yeah i mean jimmy kennedy that day
jamie kennedy yeah of uh what was it how
it was much more
malibu's most wanted yeah yeah jimmy
came to the experiment that was funny
no [ __ ] see that's like that's the day
you realize like oh [ __ ] i'm getting
paid i got on tv
that's the day you feel you felt it
because i always ask like i made a
comedian who lives in this car
oh no [ __ ] yeah he was living in his car
back then
no i didn't know that i didn't even know
either man like um
so somebody told me like no he you know
you you gotta look out for your friends
man if you're listening right now man
look out for that friend that stays
there always hangs out really late you
know like he's the last one to leave
maybe he had nowhere to go man
so um so that was jamie i didn't know
that he had nowhere to go but
he never told anybody but we always
treat him to eat you know
nice good [ __ ] damn but now the next
year man he got an mtv video and then he
don't play so good [ __ ] i mean came out
i remember that that's how it goes
it's one of those like damn that [ __ ]
was dumb but the funniest [ __ ] ever
you know it's one of those slapstick
comedies that's just forever a cult
classic
yeah man so if you have a friend man you
guys think you guys can hang around deep
smoking and everybody leaving he's
always the last one to leave you got to
ask him
you have somewhere to go homie because
sometimes they're embarrassed to tell
you man
no i feel that i've had a couple homies
like that but
that was during high school they fought
in the couch already huh
i hate that [ __ ] tell me i've had a few
friends like that well my my little
step-brother
my step-brother he lived with my dad and
my mom and he was staying over i'm like
you never fall asleep here hmm all right
and i found this fool's been living in
his car for like a month and a half
the [ __ ] he's tripping he's trippy he's
just living my house
you know what i mean i didn't realize
till like day three like
you don't have a house dude what the
[ __ ] is going on and i realized he got
kicked out
but i didn't know you were like spending
at your friend's house
you have to you have to ask your mom
when i was a kid
yeah [ __ ] you did you liked it you liked
it though
having to ask or spend the night at
night that was the
dopest [ __ ] in the [ __ ] plan it was
like yeah you might not have heard about
his mom but
the [ __ ] was my mom [ __ ] me up but at
my house my mom would go to mexico bro
like for
three almost like three weeks and just
leave us bro with oh hell another corned
beef
that's it's nastiest [ __ ] bro no knife
it was too hard oh i had it in the can
no i
had in a bag and it was like not even
cut dog
we had no sharp knives dude so every
time we made with a big
big old chunk of ground beef of um beef
corned beef dog
i hate that [ __ ] so yeah i know what
you're talking about you had the
cornbread with a camera in the can and
some people made taco with it
oh my grandma miss me like stews with it
and [ __ ] but i'm gonna be eating out of
a can when i was broke my grandpa left
for two weeks
i'm like [ __ ] i guess i'm eating frozen
hot dogs i'm thaw that [ __ ] out
eat packets of hot dogs and corned beef
nasty
man when my mom left we had a sleepover
at my house
every night every day i would just say
well
every i would tell them have to go bring
some food from your house and then we
start eating at my house
how old were you i was like 12 13 15
years old 16 15 years old
and man i remember we played this game
where we turn up the lies and we start
punching each other man yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah i've done that before the name of
it
never but the person that's getting
tired of get getting hit you got to turn
the lights on
always or the fool on the ground holding
no i oh we
it was always set up though you know we
were going to hit everybody made an eye
contact with the [ __ ] up the kid was
born
yeah i feel it there was always the key
like damn well i'm poor
you're dirty though yeah you don't got
water off this is not good
i had that homie too they could always
beat you with but i have both parents
huh you don't huh
oh damn i didn't have both parents but
still they were struggling hard too
yeah i had both parents mom and dad my
whole life growing up yeah
damn that's some sick [ __ ] though so i
would pick up like
when we were in my house we'd be picking
on the kid with no mom and dad
and they were the way the funniest too
the kids
didn't have a mom and dad to me were the
funniest kids ever for real
they had to make it up for it bro they
were gonna get picked on oh damn i never
picked up nobody
you ain't got no parents [ __ ] that's
how you know it's rough i need to get
picked on a lot of my mom had a job
where all my kids
all my friends will see her every day
more than me what where did she
work as a nurse assistant nurse at
school at
elementary school so everybody saw her
growing up so they had that
material of knowing who my mom is
rafaela esparza so everybody
so your mother rafaela oh they're
stealing bandages this year
or what time i i fell off like if i hurt
my arm hold on
i'm gonna come with an ambulance oh no
so it wasn't always like that
so that dude chris would always make fun
of my mama
how about your daddy your dad on your
that last on your birthday bro he's
telling me back on by candle never came
back
about to buy candles damn that's more
[ __ ] than cigarettes damn
yeah now leaving to leave it out on the
birthday to buy candles and not come
back that's the most evil
that's about that but we were talking
about it recently like we used to make
fun of
them kids just make fun of me i just
like well you're on section 82
[ __ ] you uh you got you you're on
welfare dude that was like the [ __ ]
i got a dad at least i see him sometimes
[ __ ] you
that was the burn like i got a dad bro
if you know
my mom she would always like um make us
join
activities at the park you know whether
like baseball
or summer camp you know or whatever
activity
available like she uh she would go to
church
she will go to church you know like you
don't know like a lot of people don't go
to church
you know like every sunday you know but
for some people they go out every day
but um you know i'm not mocking religion
but it
depends what you get out of it you know
and and where i'm
growing up catholic you know we knew how
to
we knew how to get stuff man like
catholics you know just like
christians muslim jewish people man if
you're connected to your
to your church you got friends man then
you're gonna go hungry bro
they're gonna tell you man like my mom
would go there every week she'll
volunteer so
she knew what [ __ ] was coming up
whenever there was like a fundraiser for
a summer camp
my mom was the first one you know
helping you know and we'll get in for
free
is your mom nice i feel like she's nice
she's super nice man okay that's how i'm
i'm here and like
that's a nice ass we had a different
tale from east l.a last episode
yeah [ __ ] this is different yeah
watch out for those kids you know that
the last the last guy you had like
um my mom right after uh she was not the
nurse she became the
um the program manager of the of um
unified school district for that school
yeah so after school you know when you
when
you want to go home you want to play
basketball yeah it was my mom was a
woman i'll give you a basketball
she don't want to sit with you to your
mom pick you up
and sometimes she will sit there until 6
30 it was like the cutoff line you know
but my mom is nice so these parents will
take advantage bro
and i'll be there to a [ __ ] eight you
know or 8 30.
and my mom pretty much kicked his kids
out of the school you know the school's
closed
but you know it's dark that's been me a
few times it's dark horror mother and
[ __ ]
could have given their jacket oh i hate
that was me
yeah so mama by myself and [ __ ] so my
mom was that lady so we were always like
joining different programs going to
summer school
and bro it comes to the story man my
brother
he went to elementary school called
sierra park over there in el sarino
he was a magnet student you know magnate
is like a gifted kid oh i was in that
[ __ ] i was in next year too bro from
second grade to a fifth and threw my ass
out
they threw you out yeah i think i
cheated or something
what i was in there i cheated my way
from six to eight hey
every day with [ __ ] homework bro it's
not fun oh
we got to read more [ __ ] than you sick
homework i remember my history teacher
my history teacher bro
we'll collect homework around the class
and if you don't have it
she'll give you a paper to sign you're
going to sign it and it says
um felipe esparza did not do the
assignment for today i'm gonna need you
to sign this
this is the first homework he misses
three more we're gonna have a meeting
so man you have to sign that [ __ ] this
[ __ ] will give homework during um
for the christmas vacation bro yeah i
had that too yeah for sure it was like
a project who said yeah
hell no i hated school so much horrible
kid student bro
the kind of kid bro that you you tell me
in the beginning of the classroom okay
we have a book report dude by the end of
the year
bro i will start doing that book report
bro to a [ __ ] my
lunch time bro before it's due yeah oh
you know i got three months
all day and three months is here okay
i'll do it tomorrow night
tomorrow night shows up i'll do it in
the morning tomorrow morning shows up
you know i will [ __ ] ditch that class
give me another day
yeah all day all day seriously but when
i was in like fifth grade and you had to
do it
all i would do is do it all through
lunch i'd copy different kids so i'd
have a little bit different take on each
thing
that's how i did it my friends would
help me i was like like a little rebel
in elementary school like i used to like
to
sharpen my pencil till i got through the
smallest yo
i remember that child what was it did we
just become best friends
bro i used to do it all the time
my teacher was looking you want a bigger
pencil no no it's funner than that
faster i feel the little pencil is fast
i'm left-handed too i don't know what's
going on
little joints right maybe huh i never i
don't i didn't [ __ ] with drugs as a kid
me neither bro i thought it was natural
21. no no we know nothing no man just
not even spray paint or glue nothing
what'd you do through high school
enough just lived clam trees bro
so lived your life my brother angel was
at the elementary school bro
jump on top of roofs i did that too but
this is just to smoke weed
wow that's great though my brother um he
he [ __ ] signed up bro at his magnet
school
all the kids right he got an application
and he took it home
my mom signed it i didn't know none
about this but i found out later
my brother signed up for a foreign
exchange program bro
oh [ __ ] to leave to leave to where to
mexico city bro [ __ ] pyramids bro
eating sushi lobster eating like a
[ __ ] king
well anyways he signed it bro and my
brother
got on a plane and went to mexico city
with a bunch of his kids
his students and maybe one teacher
supervisor but they all went to
different
homes my brother was living with his
rich
family his mexican family in mexico city
and he was seeing pyramids and he being
culture bro
okay and it was all great for my brother
man but this is the [ __ ] up part man
that kid has to come live with us now
too switch off
and now he's like yeah bro he was in a
[ __ ] housing project
sharing a room with three people
he got cultured too yeah he got catfish
bro he thought he was coming to beverly
hills and [ __ ]
we brought my i don't know if i said it
makes me laugh because my brother went
out to eat lobster you know
off the coast all these beaches you know
man we took that kid to go um get free
lunch at the park
for summer program we taught him about
no cut-offs
no cut-offs you mean talking about the
pants yeah oh my god
dude this dude was so cultured and
and he grew up like another first class
all the way for this kid right he's rich
bro this kid was playing pop warner
football like tackle football in
elementary school
in mexico city i didn't do that [ __ ]
here in america
no no never got a chance to do that
my brother angel got to do that too
though but we were broke
that's the one thing i did every year i
always played football
so dude that kid flies out over here bro
and he let me take him to the housing
projects bro
first night bro there's a [ __ ] gun
there's a gang shootout bro like outside
my house
like damn
and i feel so comfortable from mexico
city bro that's during a cartel time
probably
oh i got you so he was like scared at
all you know normal but
man i'd be pissed that's that's just a
rich man poor man though he's
about to went to the city i'd be [ __ ]
heated country mouse right yeah
they took my brother swimming and these
badass hotels
they had a swimming pool at their house
we took them to the swimming pool right
here in our
in our park bro he had to put his
all his all his clothes in a green bag i
never did i had a little baby cubbies
but they were open exposed he didn't
watch this dude
he could tell he he didn't grow up like
us dude like i couldn't find him one day
we were swimming i couldn't find him and
this fool was laying on a floor bro
tanning dog
he was wearing speedos bro nobody was
we have never seen nobody wears beetles
before is it high school
no this is elementary school kids this
is elementary
he's that the [ __ ] well he's he grew up
in mexico city bro he's raised
a speedo as a kid he's uh this is the
way they dress over there that's how
there's no swim trunks i guess for him
oh weird so he's just standing there bro
man that [ __ ] and we didn't know about
this where's that guy
you know they're tanning right in the
riviera what the [ __ ]
how long was he with you two weeks bro
is he like blown away like where the
[ __ ] am i i thought i was going down
there you know he just
went to complain he just took it like a
soldier what a badass
and but he was you know he's not used to
sharing you know because he gets
whatever he wants
my brother like my brother never told no
for anything
that was over there like can i have that
big ass coke yeah
could we get some of this yeah [ __ ]
here's his own room bro
that's like on television with a remote
control
there was no room the only tv we have in
the living room bro and there was only
only two channels uhf and bhf do you
remember the click once
she was kind of sick i like that yeah
to see everything flipping right on the
floor i remember that [ __ ] dude
butter he bought a ice cream and he
didn't share it bro now like four of us
hit the [ __ ] she was melting in his hand
dude
sharon and i were looking at him all
right [ __ ] we'll see what
happens
oh [ __ ] culture shock but he took it
sounds cool the next day we had like a
reunion with all the students from that
foreign exchange
and my brother took me we had like a big
picnic
that then um that kid we were with he
got into a fight with one of
the foreigners changed to them from
mexico like i guess they have beef
all the way from mexico yeah so they're
over here and now lay
going at it bro they started fighting
man and our guy got his ass beat
dog oh and i kept thinking and i
remember i told him man you know if you
were to share that ice cream
[Laughter]
that guy right now would be sucking
crying right now
just remember that life lesson and i
told him bro you want to share that ice
cream
oh
that's what he learned in america yo so
my question
as we said earlier you made it all the
way through high school you weren't
doing you were just that
you were a regular student that you see
in the movies the regular guy
yeah that's my great that's ty no that's
crazy all my friends
were like no they're not they were like
hanging they were not really in gangs
but they were up to no good but they
were not a gang yet
hold on were you born here you were born
i went in mexico um snooki in fairness
square
where you guys had see we've had a lot
of cute families had
multiple east l.a stories on here people
do not have like no i was like
i had good family and [ __ ] and you i
mean you guys are my country
my dad i think he snuck into america in
19 um
before i guess before 1978
or 77 he snuck over here i think he came
in the trunk of a car
oh damn yeah my grandpa is just neat
people too
and um and then we came here
my dad was living it was already
established you know for a year and a
half i guess
hillary that was a he had a good job
already in mexico man the people who
came from mexico man
are coming with skills you know that's
why a man like it's tough when you
complain about the immigrants well
they come over here and they really got
jobs yeah man they're coming over here
with 10 years of experience
in that job they're doing already you
know yeah you might put in bricks
but man he's kept doing he was putting
bricks in mexico too you know
somebody nobody got to show them how to
do it you know
yeah so my dad came with skills he was
like a a welder and a metal shop worker
already
in mexico so when he came over here he
easily got a job man
i don't know what kind of id he had my
mom told me that my dad was
when they were building the panama canal
in panama
it was like an american project bro they
dug out the hole in panama but the
pieces of it
were made all over america and my dad's
job was
welding part of the tunnel that they
were gonna take on a boat
to panama wow that's some historicalized
[ __ ] right there yeah so
some of the panama panama um canal was
made in a made in um
right here in norwalk somewhere no [ __ ]
for pike
meadow i think yeah that's sick dude
yeah
like you're saying uh you had to sneak
over here
um my mom we got busted
trying to sneak in like three times two
times
how were you i was well with four maybe
five you remember that [ __ ]
but i was there with my two little
brothers and my mom
without without with a smuggler i guess
yeah we were in his car i was we were in
the back seat
and we made it to the border and then
there was a a checkpoint like uh
i guess the sheriffs of san clemente
they decided to have their own roadblock
on the fire freeway you know because i
guess
the people that were complaining too
many legal were coming in yeah so this
doesn't happen no more i've never seen
that that was back in the days right
they put up a
a roadblock there it was not there
anymore and we got busted right there
and he put it in the jails
my me and my little brother went to this
jail and my mom went to this jail and
the guy that was driving they let him go
because i guess we're here american
citizen
you know he's american citizen but and
the reason they let him go now i think
about it because they're not really
they're not really border agents so they
have no right to
ask or detain you know a citizen a
citizen no matter what they have no
no evidence of anything so they just
said um we didn't write him out hey he's
a coyote
we just shut up we went to jail and they
let him go
so they take your he just basically
takes your money if we make it we make
it yeah
that's whack you know three times well
he didn't well he did take her to
america
so that was he got he's almost anyone
that got you here the second time
i don't remember how far we got i just
know we made it back and then the third
time
my aunt my gran my aunt she said
that um okay we're gonna cross but your
brother has to be a little girl
and i said we were little kids we don't
know this is a meeting the old adults
had before
behind our backs so my little brother i
started noticing wearing a dress
for about a week wait so he can cross
because i've seen your stand-ups
obviously and is this the patty one
yeah this is a real story so he was for
a bit it was a [ __ ] job
i thought you were [ __ ] around you
dressed up a little boy to look like
me my aunt not me no i got you
so for about a for about a
week he's practicing you know my name is
your name
you know they're like kind of like um
you know arguing
we're getting ready that movie argo
where they when they went in
they fled iran you know with fake
passports
so we had our characters on so my gran i
don't know what my aunt did but she
showed
my they showed the immigration
the forms and they asked my brother
what's your name my name is pati and
they took we crossed the border and then
we went to i remember going to
carson city of carson and there was a
living room
there were like five or five bedroom in
the living room
and every bedroom had a different
mexican family
and they were all gonna go and then i
think that was a hub yeah the
headquarters the headquarters
because uh there were people coming in
and out bro like in and out
like we went and they dropped us off in
boyle heights [ __ ] we had a place to go
and then there was people these people
here were going to norwalk and then like
there were some people that were going
to actually go over to chicago and then
wow some people were going to go to
texas so they were all going different
places
like this for them it was like the first
trip
of the first stop on their way to their
death and that's scary as [ __ ]
have to experience as a little kid yeah
or no or did you just take it
you're a little kid man you're looking
up they're grabbing your hand you know
you're being dragged everywhere was your
mom scared like what was her whole where
was she at during all this
my mom was already um here we were just
waiting for her to grab us
yeah she went ahead too so it was
literally just you
just my three little brothers and then
my aunts
dropped us off at that place so you're
just trying to link back
up with your ma in america last time you
saw her was in mexico
yeah wow cause she went on and we met we
met her in carson and we went to that
that's when we started living together
in boyle heights
four cell phones before all that [ __ ]
before all that man
you just started a life they just
dropped you off in ball heights and said
this is where you live now
you're gonna go to sheridan elementary
kid wow
that's how you started it oh man do you
remember mexico being like so
shitty that it was like desperate to get
here no
i remember uh mexico when i was a little
kid
i remember
i remember my uncle he would he would um
pack up hit a truck and um
there was people picking cotton it's you
know anywhere we live like a bunch of
mexican people they are picking cotton
you know and they put him in sacks
and my uncle put all the sacks in his
big ass truck and take them wherever
they have to go
but real hold on bro like [ __ ] cotton
picking brother
and um i remember um
when i was a little kid they sent me to
go buy tortillas i guess
and i was like four i guess three and i
remember playing with the money
and [ __ ] and i lost it bro ah so the
friend already they're gonna beat my ass
so i did i snuck it back into the house
and i hit under the bed for like six
hours bro why they're looking for you
they're looking for me bro they were
looking for me and every hour that
passed
i guess they were they kept looking for
me and then finally i came out of the
bay i came out of the bedroom you know
and i got the ass beating on my life
i always thought that was weird eh we
were so
worried we couldn't find you to beat
your ass no it's the relief and the
relief light you're okay
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up bro it was like my
dad wasn't even there it was my aunt
my grandfather and my grandmother and my
mom
they took a turn beating my ass it was
like a battle royal
bro yeah [ __ ] out of a little kid they
beat the [ __ ] out of me bro
you never did it again though yeah i
used to follow my i know that i took my
mom still like to follow my dad to work
all the time
and and like he would tell me to turn
around and go home you know but i was
like a straight dog you know you know
when you tell your daughter to go home
but you know
he keeps following you and um i remember
i followed my dad he said turn around
like threw a rock or something and go
back
what tough you know and um so
i remember i hid and then i forgot how
to i forgot how to get to his job and i
forgot how to get home
so i snuck into this variety show i
think
like a like a movie theater play but
they had like women dancing
i was backstage bro just checking them
out and who is this kid hey
it was a movie playing [ __ ] four [ __ ]
years old i was like three or four then
i ever went to the movie plane
and i went back home my mom said where
the [ __ ] you been and whip my ass
and the next day they tied me up to the
gate
damn i don't want to come to [ __ ] in
america too god damn they tied me up to
a gate bro like a [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
chicken
they really tied you to the fence yeah
with my ankle my mom did i remember my
mom danny
my ankle because i was leaving all of
them bro like
dude if you were not watching me i will
bowl now
what kind of kid do that if where to
grow a shopping
shop you're looking for clothes i will
hide inside the jacket but you'll never
see me
that's terrifying that's just fun that's
the most terrifying [ __ ] for you you had
a three-year-old
they just disappear in those goddamn
clothing yeah bro and then you
i will follow us i will take off and
then fall asleep somewhere bro then
oh hell no see my mom and dad were not
good parents they left me one time at
[ __ ]
kindergarten halloween things they left
me for like 45 minutes till they
realized they forgot me
i fell asleep in a toy a fake treasure
chest
your little innocent hidings weren't so
that they just didn't know this was just
yeah
you only got two they forgot you forgot
me for me like
over 20 minutes i learned this
my mom told me this my brother fernando
the one that was party
we're we're already legally here we're
already um
rather than aliens you know and my dad
took us to mexico we're in essentia bro
rosarito mexico
and we're filling up the gas station
putting up gas
my dad leaves my little brother in
rosarito and we're already in tijuana
bro
what did you guys notice i didn't know
my mom
fabricio where fabrizio at
and my mom told me that they turned
around and they went back to the gas
station and you're still standing there
how old dude he was two what the [ __ ]
two or three dogs lucky he didn't run
off
he was just standing there bro like
still waiting
like like he must have been alone for uh
a good
hour and a half damn that's terrifying
that's a tough
guy bro it's tough i would have lost my
mind getting left like that
[ __ ] no i'd be scared of [ __ ] i just
realized i haven't smoked
i ain't even looked at this thing when i
was a kid
that was my that was my main thing bro
getting locked leaving my family in
disneyland bro i'm going on my own
when i was younger that kid oh no i
would've had to tell you like
accidentally
hell no bro like like i'm i'll be like
wandering around like i'm gonna go look
at this and then they disappear on me
and instead of going to los angeles you
start getting out of the ride for myself
but without with the like i'm with him
you know i'm with her mm-hmm
yeah yeah yeah basically yeah
when i was in the mall one time this was
scared me i was like four years old
everyone always like hold your kid's
hand like now you don't let your
three-year-old go to the store to buy
tortillas you'll let your three or go to
the bathroom alone no
no hell no not now literally [ __ ] when
you were when i was a little kid
i was i was five i remember kids will
have we'll take a little
five-year-old kids would take a note to
a liquor store yeah it's okay to start
my kids cigarettes
oh damn yeah daddy i never did that
yeah no um i was in line at [ __ ]
sbarros
at the mall and i'm standing there and
some teenager girl
probably 18 just grabs my arm starts
pulling me toward the door and i'm
pulling back on my three and i started
screaming no
and no one's doing nothing and she gets
me almost to the door
out the door 40 yards away i'm screaming
in the mall shut up yeah and then she
looks down and she almost starts crying
and then some little boy dressed in the
exact same clothes as me runs up
she thought i was her little brother
she's trying to almost kidnap my ass out
the line of sabaro's
and i lost my place in line dude
jesus pissed i was doing i said mom
so random crazy i was doing this show
i forgot where oh probably um
virginia somewhere in um virginia
and um some guy that hooked us up with
some bud you know he came out and we
were just
smoking with him on the patio of the the
hotel
and we just stopped talking about la
because he said his dad
was in la you know and um baby mama
right
so um baby mama problem with his dad you
know and his mom and
he said that his mom was going through
some problems you know and um
and she was over there with his little
sister living in l.a or
laulay i guess so he went to go grab her
because the mom was all drugged out you
know
so he went over there to the house keep
the door down grabbed the little girl
and just took it with him
and had been raising her ever since he
took the wrong girl
get the [ __ ] out of here i hope that was
a joke no no joe he told me
his dad took the wrong girl not as it
not his daughter
not his daughter bro but it wasn't it
was just a
random another little girl that was
living in a crackhead house bro with
crackheads
oh gosh she was there to grab his
daughter
but he ended up grabbing the other girl
i said so they've just been
that girl doesn't really have parents
either so they just been raising her
little kids get abandoned like that
that's sad as [ __ ] yeah i think about
that all the time when i look at my kids
damn that's what you think i just never
leave you guys
you guys got it it's so good you're slow
oh yeah yeah
delicate balance so many kids don't have
it like that you have kids
yeah yeah i have kids i have a
two-year-old grandson
like oh [ __ ] that gets in trouble
already in school do you really
what how old is your kid that has a kid
my wife i have kids when i was in high
school bro you know i
had a oh no [ __ ] damn i got a girl
pregnant
school bro and i was young bro and um
immature like every high school kid
every junior high school kid you know
so you were doing some crazy [ __ ] i
remember she told me i was [ __ ]
i wasn't doing drugs she told me i was
like i was at every house party bro
trying to get my grind on
the only one not drunk and [ __ ] yeah bro
i remember oh you know she told me
felipe i'm pregnant
and i remember saying man that [ __ ] up
that you're going to raise a baby by
yourself
yo how old were you like 17.
she didn't find the comedy in that but
you know what
when i won last comic standing she got
me her child support
no she became the last bay mama stan
yo i'm glad you could make fun of me
getting got like real girls you said
that i played it all
bro like the kids were over 18. she'd
have to share with them it was all hers
oh [ __ ] wait hold on
she saw you on tv and realized that then
no she probably knew who i was but she
didn't know i was gonna blow up like
that
man she probably had all her friends
voting for me man
baby daddy yeah we're trying to get
white tennis shoes for everybody
kids damn you still owe it even though
the kid is beyond 18.
you can't just cut the ketchup anybody
out there holds child support
i suggest you go to a place called um
uh united fathers of america if you're
looking for help that's the only player
that's going to help a baby daddy
united falls of america they help you go
get um
your child support reduction they'll
help you get visitations
and most of the lawyers they use are
women so you have a woman fighting for
you
because the way it looks bad when you
have a a man lawyer and you're trying to
fight a woman and [ __ ] in court do you
have lower payments
yeah yeah i get it but i didn't go
through that bro i just didn't
i said screw it you know he just here's
the advice i didn't [ __ ] do it i
didn't do it
don't make my mistake so yeah so you one
last comment status you went
no no no no i used to have jokes about
it bro i met my daughter on facebook
did you what do you mean she would leave
message yeah we didn't get the child
support
to block her
[Laughter]
yo you had two kids with this lady two
of them bro
the same lady from high school same girl
yeah when would you have your daughter
right after
about a year two years later
oh [ __ ] she's the one that has a baby
right now wow so you're really our
grandpa
yeah man it's like i didn't well i
wasn't there to raise my daughter
you know but i'm here to raise her
grandson now and i'm gonna have to
because you know
i don't want to bring the show into a
down in a downer you know but i'm a
positive guy
my daughter has um terminal breast
cancer she was diagnosed with terminal
breast cancer last december
your daughter yeah wait your
my daughter yeah from my son my grandson
yeah
so she's like i'm going through the
treatments right now and um
and getting her bones already you know
so she just
like uh she's just fitting her her first
um
her first chemo so she's not waiting for
the second one you know
she lost her hair and her eyebrows yeah
yeah
so i've been watching her the baby a lot
you know because she's always tired you
know
so this helps i give her this i give her
a lot of this yeah i'm sorry for that
no man you know hey man this is this is
life you know
i'm glad that i'm in a position where i
could help you know
help her you know i have because of what
i do stand-up comedy
i'm home a lot you know i'll go home out
of town on the weekends
especially this past year i would
imagine yes and my daughter
found out that she had cancer when she
was living in sweden with her
her boyfriend doing what no she had a
boyfriend you know
who lived in sweden and they were living
together what a random place to live i
know right
what the she was over there for two
years and he hooked up with a guy and um
my grandson is half um persian half
mexican in sweden
really posh kahani that's the last name
that's uh i don't think i've ever heard
of that i've never trampled before
nah nah i've i mean i've heard of sweden
like that place is nice as [ __ ] i never
heard anybody living from there
yeah man it's really nice and she would
she would live in
during a pandemic oh so this is recent
that you're saying this
yeah just recent so she left sweden she
left um
full full health 100 full health to come
over here
but um she's doing good over here
matches she goes she gets her chemo done
and um yeah doing good
[ __ ] that's rough dude um yeah no i went
my
my uncle went through that last year
yeah it wasn't good
yeah you know it's funny um when i was
um i remember um
i went to the um to watch the
documentary for this woman who who had a
heck when um she had cancer i don't know
if it was breast cancer but she had
cancer
but uh the documentary was about her
going all natural
without chemo oh no she was gonna do it
on her own
with natural foods very painful by the
way to do
go through this but she did it she beat
it you know she beat it you know
she beat the cancer with going through
um she wasn't there like a weird type of
chemo but she didn't do the chemo
cumulative everybody does
she did our organics and fruits and i
remember
sitting there with this actor i don't
know if you ever you know who pepe cerna
is
he comes out in a he comes out in
american me
which character he's the one that comes
out eight so you're gonna come out to
90.
he's the first kid the mean one the mean
one yeah
he played mundos well i remember we were
watching the documentary he looked
he goes [ __ ] that i did the chemo oh
hell no
so he went through chemo for it the
natural way yeah
it sounds like the way to go honestly
like all what was the high alkaline
diets and [ __ ]
yeah alkalized everything all greens
rso cbd that's tough it's like at that
point it's
like i don't know i mean chef your dad
went through this too
yeah he there wasn't nothing natural he
just went for the straight up
medical treatment options and [ __ ] there
was no
other real options but you know
it was a back and forth for a long time
for a long time uh yeah yeah eight years
yeah my daughter go to the city it was
going to a city of hope
but now she transferred to the valley of
one closer so
so yeah man well good we're good i mean
i hope everything works out
just try try the hot alkalized diet
appear high ph
water i've i've watched a lot of
documentaries i've seen this really help
out
i know man you don't even think about it
man if you're a woman listening man or a
chubby guy with big titties they
i'll see go get a diagram uh diagram no
monogram man mammogram mammogram
monogramming
yeah i'm going to draw my boobs
[Laughter]
yeah so it's funny man like my my
grandson like you know
because you know he's two years old he's
been through a lot you know moving to
another country yeah
he was learning he was speaking swedish
over there now he has to speak full
english you know because his grandmother
was speaking just swedish
and his dad and now he comes you over
here
english and then you put him in school
and he would live
he was moving around a lot so it's tough
on a two-year-old kid man
but the school he's that they're very
patient you know and
um they got like a daycare no montessori
school you go there from two years old
to
vlog sixth grade i never heard that in
my life too yeah you gotta find them bro
yeah those are nice schools they serve
like real lunches like an actual
date and it's like polishing yes no
peanuts everybody
yeah it's like peanut free place that's
nice
um so damn i didn't yeah i didn't know
you had kid then that's that was my
reason
yeah man right [ __ ] 1980 and late 80s
early 90s
i never really i didn't consider it i
wouldn't have even thought about that
damn well you wear well i didn't realize
you were having kids that
that's a long time ago i know right
people look at me and go man believe
you look good felipe i know but i look
like a 30 year old guy who needs a nap
huh
i'm not putting it past it i gotta be
honest so were you you said you were
acting when you started doing stand up
which which were you really getting
after no i was doing stand up first
i didn't start acting or getting into
acting until 2005
oh what i started taking acting classes
in 2004
no 2005 i was um
i auditioned for the montreal comedy
festival in montreal canada
and i made it it's a big deal so i went
over there with a bunch of other
comedians and
i was showcased with a bunch of young
comics i killed it
and i was signed by agency man uta
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah united italian
agency yeah and they took me man i
wasn't ready dude i was not
an actor i was not even going to acting
classes but they were taking me to
[ __ ]
they would take me to auditions and i
was messing them all up
i went to audition for a natural library
bro but not for nacho liberty
i auditioned for one of the priests ah
see that stick
and i remember man when i saw the guy
who got the part
he was [ __ ] how come i didn't do it
like that
i've had diarrhea you know
oh man yeah i haven't had diarrhea you
know i could have just been i could have
done it like this i haven't taken the
[ __ ] since easter
yo i'm so glad you said that i was gonna
tell you
i want to bring up a segment to certain
guests like i got one question
can you remember the first time you [ __ ]
your pants in public and i feel like
since you said that
you're gonna remember the first thing
because it's like it happens more than
once in your life
as a kid and then maybe as an adult but
do you remember the first time bro when
you
you taking a [ __ ] in your pants in a
classroom
your face looks like you just blocked a
kick to the face
you're like this yo you're [ __ ] in the
classroom
oh god i'm not i know i
didn't sh you had to think about that
one
no i don't think i ever shared my path
but only on drugs you know that's normal
what drugs coke you know you get a bad
cold with with too much of that
in a classroom no not in class an adult
i don't call it a class you gotta throw
your underwear through your underwear
through your door you [ __ ] your pants
with bad coke brother i had too much of
that baby powder or something
really i never had it like that i i'm
from up there it's all meth cut up
yeah man they cut it with um baby try
baby um black slips laxatives yeah oh
what the [ __ ] that sounds yeah man
you're doing bombs and taking that in
their
massive diarrhea oh sweat and smoking
cigarettes talking too much
that sounds like a terrible night so you
don't remember the first time you ever
shoot your pants and pull up i don't
remember the first time i stayed in my
probably farting and sharing my pants
i didn't know what it was man i remember
throwing the underwear away
somebody catching me i i remember my
[ __ ] my pants at a taco shop
waiting for the bathroom after soccer
practice oh like that that's an annoying
i don't think they were i peed on myself
i just had to ask man i feel like you're
the guy who goes yeah i remember it was
like kentucky fried chicken
and i was waiting in line like my [ __ ]
uh-huh well i peed up myself
and i remember i jumped i jumped the
gate bro and i went i went to um
i went to um i went to a laundromat bro
and um
and i put my clothes in somebody's dryer
when they were drying it when they left
so you had no clothes on as you're
[ __ ] doing it yeah i just wrapped
myself with one of the plastic
trash bags and just waiting for my pants
to dry how old were you damn
i was like nine or ten eleven oh you see
you still have time to wait till high
school so nobody remembers
i get that i'm talking about but i
farted in class thought was it more
embarrassing bro
i did that in second grade i remember
everybody i started in class
there used to be a kid they used to
bully me from second grade or fifth
grade
and then bully you yeah just like
bullying me like
like there's like a i put up mud like
he'll throw it in my head you know stuff
like that
but not really like grab me and stuff
and like do stupid [ __ ] like that yeah
and i would just ignore it
you know but um that one day man
i farted in class real hard and stunk
bro
and they said this food just took a [ __ ]
this would just farted and i got so
impressed
so embarrassed dog that he yelled it out
that i grabbed him by the shirt and
started punching and sharing him bro
i didn't fart [ __ ] you [ __ ]
shot you [ __ ] shitty [ __ ]
and um i just started punching him
repeatedly bro to the
police the [ __ ] um the the teacher
stopped me bro and after that he stopped
bullying me bro like i don't give a [ __ ]
i would like he could bully me call me
gay
throw dirt in my face but don't say i
[ __ ] in my pants
i rather get remembered together with a
[ __ ] than the guy who's sharing his
pants
yo that's super strong you don't want to
be [ __ ] man brush this forever but this
is the real [ __ ] you can't [ __ ] your
pants
and you can't [ __ ] be a [ __ ] other
than that i'd rather be a [ __ ] than a
guy who's [ __ ] in his pants bro
a [ __ ] you could just you could ride
with that [ __ ] bro yeah you could still
move out of town land a girl if you're a
[ __ ] some dumb [ __ ] will [ __ ] date
you
but if you're the guy that shits your
pants at an assembly i have friends
brother who are [ __ ] in their pants
and you start smelling it and each other
you try to like smile behind them and
then
they get forward they move forward why
because they shouldn't have passed bro
why do you have homies [ __ ] in their
pants but they don't
i didn't know you know just growing up
you smell it hey somebody shouldn't have
passed
[Laughter]
what you're always doing
what's up everybody it's that time again
this is the mid role ad read thank you
guys again so much for supporting
everything supporting our sponsors
supporting manscaped as always guys hit
www.manscape.com forward slash yola you
can click the link in the description on
our youtube channel right below in
description or you can click the links
on spotify apple google podcast anywhere
you watch us
we have the link for manscaped remember
that gives you 20 off plus free shipping
you guys already know the deal this is
manscaped in my opinion the number one
mail grooming kit
male grooming products in the world i
personally use this my homie standing
over there on his phone personally uses
this [ __ ] thank you guys again so much
for using the code using the link 100
you guys are helping out so much we're
seeing people buy we're seeing people
use the code so thank you this is the
newest product for manscape this is the
lawnmower 4.0
it's a sensitive area guys it's a
sensitive subject so be careful don't
cut your dick open
you like that one marty you like that
one
so you'll be happy to know this is 100
skin safe this is not going to pinch
it's not going to cut you because we've
all been there
it's not fun it's a real part of life
and if you've never shaved yourself
damn damn son
don't even know where to go with that
just damn son
this has wireless charging guys this has
a light on it for all you blind ass
fools out there this has a light on it
and as you know it's waterproof that's
the biggest that's the biggest selling
point for me
this is waterproof you guys you guys
know from guy to guy you guys know
it's a sensitive [ __ ] area so as
always guys we just want to say shout
out to our sponsor thank you so much to
manscaped
go to www.manscape.com forward slash
yola or click the link like i said in
the descriptions or anywhere you watch
the podcast as always that's 20
off plus free shipping as always thank
you for supporting thank you for using
the links
back to the episode yo what i have
but i've had girls farting my face
bro now
you keep going you keep going like a
soldier bro
you're a coke bro you want more oh man
so you used to [ __ ] dabble in drugs
that's one of my questions do you used
to [ __ ] with drugs heavy yeah
man in before i went to rehab i was a
crackhead you know oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] with drugs heavy yeah man
like to smoke crack out of a [ __ ]
little ratchet a little metal thing
oh you were that full yeah i bet you
were ball headed and skinny at the time
too
no i was a little bald but i was i
wasn't asking any man no
i would eat after me that's how i was a
coke
yeah i smell crack once like once that
i'd seen
it was the worst feeling ever man i
don't know how you
explain to me what did you like about it
i don't know
the power it gave me you just feel good
man like
all your problems are your problems do
you think you had go away
you know what they're still there but
our cocaine you feel like you could
handle lady
you could walk like if you had a lot of
problems
and you do cocaine with cocaine you know
the problems are there
but cocaine is lying to you and telling
you that you could solve them right away
i got this we're going to handle this
but you know you're good
yeah yeah that's why man like i wish
that i could do cocaine
just to the point you know like when you
do cocaine you know you do
cocaine but then this is part of the a
part of when you're partying with your
friends and you and i were him
and we're drinking and like there's a
point
when we're partying where you're coming
up with business ideas bro
yeah we should start off this business
bro you're right we should do another
bump
yeah i wish we could i could do cocaine
just to that moment and then stop
and just stop and really break and then
break down the idea of how to start the
business bro
how to get a load that's all right man
you're gonna [ __ ] call up the bank
tomorrow okay call the [ __ ] you're
calling right now
and you're gonna [ __ ] we're gonna do
this i'm gonna look for a space
and we're gonna do this right but now
man what happens is you keep doing more
cocaine
then your friend hits you well but
whatever to that business shut up they
don't six days ago
let's try to bring it to this house
right now i'm trying to sell my
refrigerator
like if you could just do enough cocaine
just to get to the point where you want
to start a business
and stop academic bumps yeah
financial lines i saw a movie bro i saw
a movie this i saw a dutch movie it was
nominated for an award
it was called um it's called um
another round it was called another
round another round with like another
round of drinks
and these older older dutch guys in
their 50s they got together and they
started
they started like they started drinking
together and writing down notes
how the alcohol felt at this hour how do
you feel at this hour and they're all
professors
at a high school you know there are
professors at high school and they're
giving another words
given now assignments and then they they
got to the point where they're most
creative
so they only drank to the part where
they got creative
where they got the confidence to really
open up and really run a class you know
to
give that extra edge so they were all
doing it just to get to the edge
and their classes they were more they
were because they came became popular
teachers
the students were all into them and then
they and they even the soccer coach
was doing was doing it but then you know
like everything else they started
abusing it you know and then they felt
loud
so my thing you know my joke is i wish
you could do enough cocaine just to get
creative you know that's cool you know
what i mean it gets to the point where
you want to write a book and rewrite it
and then you actually write instead of
eating the pages there
yeah she should do [ __ ] code for
maybe like five or six years total
um but if you're saying you're smoking
crack were you smoking coke or smoking
crack crack bro
damn rocks actual rocks bro like where i
i
the difference between a cocaine
attitude hell yeah bro cocaine a kraken
cocaine you know like all right your
friend will tell you you know what i'ma
stop that way
you say yeah i'ma stop too but then he
goes to sleep and you do his cooking
but in the morning you tell him listen
man i'm sorry man i just cannot stop
but the crackhead is different man
crackhead you tell him i'm gonna stop
and he goes yeah i'm gonna stop too
but then he'll smoke all your [ __ ] but
then in the morning he's helping you
look pretty
damn that's a good that sounds like a
good way to push that i like that that's
a math head tooly
it's yeah there's scandal bringing the
worst out of people is what you're
saying
yeah worse my dad used to do craig for
like not 18
19 years my dad's a functioning one
like truck driver always always there
always on time sleep for three days
because he's been up for six type [ __ ]
but he always worked so i didn't know my
dad was so [ __ ] up until i got
when i always said like i was trying to
smoke weed on the other side of the
house and he was trying to like snort
crank
the other side of the house and i
thought i was sneaking around but really
he was like oh he's smoking weed all
right
that's how i could were you doing stand
up while you were like addicted to
cracking [ __ ] i was sober
for 10 years and then i uh like nothing
nothing nothing nothing and then i fell
off the wagon
in bakersfield california of course
bakersfield
i was doing a gig there and right after
the show
this dj he he asked me if i wanted a
drink and i wasn't drinking i said all
right take a drink
took three shots then he asked me
then he asked me wanted a bump oh i
thought you never asked
so then after i did that and then i was
up
all night the next day i was hungry i
ate
the fattest breakfast burrito at rick's
burgers
and then i thought i was gonna stop but
three days later
i drank again and i partied again then
after that i would stop for three days
and the next you know i'm up for five
days
bro over there hanging out with 10 years
on drew street over there on by the
avenues
yeah they're so so just like that ten
years after a show
yeah man it's like it's like um
every drug addict lies to themselves and
says that you know what to this time i'm
going to do it right
no you never do you can do it all wrong
you know no matter where you left off
the last time you stop
that's where you're gonna start up again
like if you're dirty and nasty and
smelling like [ __ ] the last time you
stopped doing drugs
you're gonna be dirty and smelly and
nasty
the next time you start up again within
a week you'll be back
like you never left damn dude it's so
sad
that what happened to me man like so
then i was doing stand-up comedy and
smoking crack for real man man
when i was in montreal i found crack in
montreal so you were actively going
out getting gigs and smoking crack
nobody knew nobody knew
what a life to live like that i was in i
remember in
montreal i wanted to buy some you know i
was all pumped up
after my good set and um i don't know i
didn't speak um french
they were they speak french in montreal
but i made a pace out there a mexican
dude get the [ __ ] out of it there was a
mexican dude right there bro
you were just standing there and i said
and i spoke to him in spanish anyway
i don't speak french so he went over
there man
and he spoke um french of the mexican
accent
and he came over there and he brought
the guy with me and he introduced them
to me and he spoke to me in english and
it was after
dawn after that i gave that guy 10 euros
for helping me and that was it
wow damn so you're just cracked out
it's like it can't be easier when you're
on stage in a foreign country too
no man i wouldn't wait till after the
show and i'll get your [ __ ] down first
i'll disappear
got you well i mean you're getting your
[ __ ] done but when did you realize like
what the [ __ ] how long that go off where
you're doing
shows and doing hard cause coke
everybody [ __ ] does coke besides
marty and me i guess
i had to stop man i had to stop i'm like
i was too fat i can't be doing coke like
this i'm fat
i'll die so when did you realize
like holy [ __ ] this is too much because
if you're on tour
i think i was in montebello california
and i ran into an old friend of mine
from el salvador and like he was like a
bit
i don't even know who he was just he's
an acquaintance i knew but
i didn't know him as a drug addict he
didn't know me as a drug addict we just
know like hey what's up man you're funny
oh thanks for coming to my show oh
you're funny
that was it then he goes hey man you
want to party
all right so go to his house dude
and we just partied for like five days
we partied from wednesday night all the
way to monday
like i got so bad because and he was
like a a
not a he worked at like at a pharmacy
he's a pharmacist yeah so we were like
doing blow and doing um
xanax but i've never done xanax you know
we're trying to balance it out bro you
know
you gotta protect that hard [ __ ] [ __ ]
that
so i couldn't stop he couldn't stop so
he called up
two of his big homies and his two big
homies came
in and they cleaned us up and they
cleaned up the whole house
and they they helped us get sober and
wow
they called my girlfriend for me to pick
me up because i couldn't call couldn't
move my mouth
and that's it
i left this house and he went to rehab
and on salvador and i haven't seen him
since
yeah you went through he had two of them
soon another rehab i just continued i
stayed
bro you remember when ben affleck his
last time he fell off the wagon
and he was with his ex-girlfriend in a
back seat crying
crying like a little girl at a
jack-in-the-box or a burger king
he went in a fight he fell off the wagon
and win a five-day good run bro without
doing drugs ben affleck yeah he went on
a five-day run with
uh uh an actress just a girl trying to
be an actress
and then you know when he felt bad he
caught up with the ex-girlfriend to pick
him up somewhere
and i was in a back seat crying bro you
could see your boogers coming out of his
nose
crying bro and i was laughing
and i felt bad and i felt bad for him
because i've been that i've been there
i know i know what he's thinking about
man he's probably promising him in the
world
eating a [ __ ] eating a
jack-in-the-box burger and two bites
you know he feels like [ __ ] bro
everything's coming down his life
that's that low and i've been that low
before
that's how low you get bro when you're
in the back seat eating a burger a
sandwich and your kids looking at you
like man daddy's eating a hamburger fast
dang i like i told you that's what you
catch my dad man
i might have to eat a whole costco pizza
as big as a table it's a [ __ ] costco
pizza
i've seen my dad eat a whole thing and
fast out for days and that's when i
realized like this motherfucker's on
drugs
as a kid i was a kid but then i started
doing drugs so were you like doing drugs
heavy on the road or were you mainly
just in la like dude no i know wherever
bro like on the road
after a good gig if i have money you
know like i will spend my money on the
dope
really getting spots like i remember man
um
i'm not bragging man it's all it's all
bad stuff but
you don't think about what you're doing
i remember i remember and um
i was doing a show in dallas and i was
desperate
and i called up room service and i
ordered a spoon
with and a baking soda
you trying to make crack damn you [ __ ]
with the heavy like that
yeah they brought it bro you know the
security guard and uh
in the front desk and i thought how come
you brought him oh he didn't believe me
order a
spoon and making sure he didn't believe
me
only if you're desperate like that would
you call for some [ __ ] like that
oh my god you must have really wanted
that i mean coke i understand if you
smoke crack it's so
it's so it's not the same [ __ ] way
shape or form
like it's a whole different feeling
whole different thing everything's
different if you smoke that crack though
you got your [ __ ] you're in your hotel
room how long until you're completely
desperate for that next bit of crack
though is it like the next day
or days later i think once i
when uh from for me from experience like
if i were to go on a five-day bin
you know bender i was probably like
feel like [ __ ] for like eight out of
nine i probably sleep for a day and a
half first of all
yeah and then when i wake up i'm
starving and like i feel like the
biggest
loser you know and then like a day later
like um
my mind is telling me you're you're fine
you know nobody knows you're a crackhead
you could conquer the world again so
they'll start drinking again and then
just go back
so we'll stop for about three days four
days and then go back
those are the worst type of crackheads
you know the function the ones that
could function and party for five days
and stop
because there's the people that would
party with are people that would just
smoke crack every day
yeah yeah you're hanging out with the
crowd and they're like oh this feels
cool nice cool and he'll come back in a
few days don't trip
and they don't when you're on drugs
three days like oh
i thought it was a few hours you're spun
the [ __ ] well you you're on a different
level
you're doing five days you don't know
where you're at when i think about it
now i'm like wow man who has that much
who has that much time to
to waste that's crazy i'm pretty sure
you don't have eight hours to waste like
that
you don't have three hours to waste like
that i don't have five minutes to wait
like that
but i guess i don't know how much
there's like
when i talk about it now like you don't
smoke a small crack no more why that's
so much [ __ ] to do now
that had nothing to do yeah i mean
[ __ ] boredom and
time is the worst thing in the world
especially when you live in a bad
neighborhood and you grow up around that
[ __ ]
well to say an idle mind is a devil's
playground something
something like that right or idle hands
or something like that right
yeah so in 2009
my wife was just my wife now my
girlfriend and co-mat she's like my
business partner and manager lisa good
[ __ ]
she um you know we spoke together i'm
gonna leave your ass
but i really didn't i'm gonna leave your
ass if you don't stop but
that could or not that could have never
like worked you know if i really wanted
to stop
because i could always say well i'm
gonna stop and let's do it and still do
it behind her back but i really want to
stop oh you were hiding from her too
you know you could only go for so long
man wow so i stopped
in 0.9 and i got
i got a movie man in 09 i met a guy that
wanted to
that wanted to grab my cd and make it
into a movie
really yeah what is it it's called i'm
not like that no more
and it's a movie and i'm the star of it
and paul drew is my father and
no [ __ ] nine this guy paid me money
he paid me four figures for the rights
to do my comedy into a movie
and i gave him the money you know i gave
him a cd
he wrote me a check he hired a
screenwriter and a director
and that guy got transferred my stand-up
comedy into a 80-minute movie
which i starred as felipe valenzuela
and my friend edwin san juan was my best
friend in the movie and um we made a
movie bro
we shot it in nine days and um
i don't own the rights of it but every
once in a while on youtube on christmas
i release it
no [ __ ] but i have a movie brother
we shot in 0.9 and then um
in 2010 i went last comic standing so
everything
after i sobered up uh good things
happened started
filling that time you had i one last
comic standing
and then i went on the road for a long
time
i remember my i got a check bro from a
club
i never made that much money bro i was
like
they they told me they were gonna give
me guaranteed five thousand dollars
for the whole week good [ __ ] and then
they told me and if you sell out the
shows we're going to give you an extra
500.
so i remember i sold out all the shows
they were letting people in free but
more people
paid than people they wanted to get in
for free
no [ __ ] i got a bonus there that's how
you look so i started
so now every now when i go to that same
club now
they gave me 85 percent of the door
wow crazy because i never i never i
never said i'm like [ __ ] you guys pay me
more
you know i just grew up i grew with them
so they take care of me now
where's that at the um brea improv which
i'm going to be there in july
is this in l.a yeah very i've never been
there oh yeah
no it's a legit it's one of the big
clubs around here yeah there's bread
there's irvine there's ontario
oh everyone right hollywood we're
starting to have those talks about
getting out and doing some live podcasts
these spots you should bro you have a
big following
yeah people show up too man like
support's real
yeah man sports i think well you
obviously know it's when you laugh you
can make someone laugh or somebody like
feels it it's like when you're a k i
always be coming here like all the
simpsons are here oh bart wouldn't do
that [ __ ] but you know that person you
know
everything about him even though you
never met him i mean it's a cartoon but
as for me that's who i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah so to give that feeling to somebody
and he wants to he wants to really get
into live comedy so that's like the
perfect way i feel like the live podcast
is a great way to
dip your toe into actual live comedy
with the format of the podcast and
people
not that real expectation of like i'm
gonna sit here and stare at you and
you're gonna make me laugh like there is
with the stand-up show
you know we did that for fighter and the
kid early on and it like it
really brought the fans together yeah
right people people go
yeah so we'll see you know what's your
thoughts on on
on stand-up live comedy right now at the
world opening back up
oh man i'm so excited people are so
excited to go out
man like my last show i did was in south
padre island the show was supposed to
start at eight o'clock
but there was so much traffic it was
only one bridge to come from brownsville
texas to
south padre island south padre island
is like in the gulf of mexico it's like
um if i should describe it
it's like this ocean here ocean over
there and ocean over there
and ocean over there then there's a
bridge that shows up from brownsville
texas
and brownsville is right next to the
border of mexico
so you go to the gulf of mexico south
padre island and
uh man it is [ __ ] hard bro
they started off with 500 seats sold out
and then they added more seats because
the kobe restrictions
then it was eleven hundred then they
opened it up to um three thousand bro
what is it an amphitheater yeah
so we ended up having two thousand
people damn damn good [ __ ] so the show
started at eight it started at 9 35
and uh they kept telling me i fully paid
man there's still a lot of people in
traffic over there
and i kept looking and it looked like um
them
like the movie or fill the dreams i knew
you're gonna say that they look like
that bro all you see is red red red red
red
coming our way and 100 degrees
and um that was um that was fun man
people
were loaded bro when was this um last
saturday
oh this is recent oh [ __ ] it's open to
people no
there was no mass restrictions in south
padre island like everywhere i went
i didn't wear a mask and then when i
wear a mask they laughed at me when i
changed them to a hotel room this was
the first hotel room i've ever been to
since the pandemic where
the front desk was wearing no masks
that's weird getting back
it's weird but it's getting back to life
was today the first day
you're out here today no the 15 no
today's 15th
okay today when i'm gonna go buy that
bread i brought you guys yeah
i asked that lady should i put in my
math and she told me no you know yeah
same thing really i was getting pizza i
was like damn this is weird half and
half with the masks and the pizzeria
let's get back to life though but i did
shows during the pandemic
i think i went to in august i went to
oklahoma city
how did you perform like they were uh
half capacity
with mass if you're drinking and if
you're laughing and put your mask on and
they were taking temperatures
if you're laughing put your mask on did
it feel like [ __ ] was it horrible or did
did it not bother you not for me because
i don't wear a mask on stage
no the seat not see people's i felt bad
because
more people wanted to come but they
couldn't come in but this is the funny
part man
we get there we're wearing masks they
told us to wear masks and
right outside the the club there's a
marijuana shop right there in oklahoma
city because everyone want to leave yeah
let's go
so marijuana shop and the three pastor
these guys wearing no masks and
everybody want to hit a bow and they
pass me the bow and i said now
and it goes my friend will hit it so i
left my friends there and he hit him
both of those guys
and right across the street from the
comedy club there was a full-on
country concert no mask
our capacity for cody wilson or cody
something
a country singer damn so the world's
opening back up
below nothing july bro oh last july wait
that was what the [ __ ]
yeah that was last august oh you did say
that
damn they were not giving a [ __ ] what i
said bro what tour is he on they the
colbert free tour
yeah but everything in oklahoma city was
closed like the dodgers dodged where the
dodgers played oklahoma city dodgers
i'll try to go there get an okc dodger
shirt oklahoma city dodgers it's a minor
league team triple a
never heard of that that's where kershaw
come from that's where i'm
ugly that's where all they all come from
oh you're mad at the baseball you just
need
two people right now so i don't follow
so um
i went over to buy merch [ __ ] clothes
i went to another place
closed closed closed but we were open
and that um
country western concert was open so [ __ ]
it
everybody there were some clubs in the
city bars that were open
but not the main things were open like
mcdonald's you have to
um you can drive that as a comic you you
got to think about like you don't want
people coming out to your show and then
i went out to felipe's show now i got
kovit i came home and killed my mom with
the coven
i mean that that happens like that's
been a huge thing it almost killed
comedy
yeah it did man and i did a show
and um these are students i went to i
went to florida i went to texas
but my craziest show where i where i was
surprised they were open
i went to portland oregon in november
and they were um they had a curfew too
nobody out at night after nine oh i
remember that nobody has to out after
ten
and no alcohol sold after nine pm so all
my shows
were only a hundred people a night i had
two shows every night
and the show below believe me we were
out of there before nine
really and the whole the whole city was
shut down
every night there was a fire somewhere
in the city or around
those rooms right that's right it was
still november bro november
there was um it was man it was chaos
there was like no more tourists
the pendleton store they haven't um they
have a pendleton store and
portland where where they started and
they were only living in two people at a
time
inside with mass got crazy
it's opening back up though it's
starting to feel i see people outside at
first i saw people at restaurants like
hey go home [ __ ] and now i'm
like hey you guys won't go to a
restaurant
it's i feel like it's time to go before
everything closed i hit up all the
restaurant and i wanted to go
my wife at night nice where do you guys
stay we went to a restaurant we live in
a valley but we went to a restaurant
this
yeah i went there last thursday i [ __ ] a
week ago yeah he knows all the best
vegan spots
yeah yeah man and then we went there and
we had another place and then after that
shut down you eat hell vegan [ __ ] yeah
nice
good [ __ ] so do you feel like you have
to get back on the road for like a year
before you're ready to do another
special or you feel like you got it in
you now
i think i could do it now but it's not
going to be the way i want it but it's
going to be funny
yeah because i wrote a lot of material
during that pandemic
and you know grandpa now yeah so i wrote
this because i know that
i didn't work from from march to
september
so i say that this is the first time my
life my cousin from mexico were sending
me money
[Laughter]
[ __ ] they sent back the clothes i sent
them i started re-gifting the [ __ ]
i wasn't afraid of that i wasn't afraid
of growing a virus at first bro [ __ ]
i should do cocaine off the floor yo
i've picked a
many of coke little rocks off the floor
in the carpet you're not sure if it's
old food
yeah like oh no oh styrofoam
[ __ ] like that that's the worst feeling
that's when you feel like a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
i've done i've done that [ __ ] with weed
before though so that's different you
just dropped your weed man that's a
whole
you're not searching out of [ __ ]
cocaine with weed right you start
looking
that's the worst time when you start
looking for a little nug uh-huh in all
the wrong places
you have that little shot of hope you
ever like do that like
when you have like no more weed but you
have that ball that's black as hell
you start scraping oh the resin hits the
resin hits
i haven't done this since probably about
15 16. yeah when i lived in buffalo that
was standard procedure that was just
he's from the east coast my wife too
she's from ohio so that was standard
oh [ __ ] your wife is white i'm assuming
yeah
oh no from dayton ohio but she was
she lived in new york she lived in
aurora colorado she lived a lot of
places
where'd you guys meet the life factory
no [ __ ]
you're just doing a set yeah she was a
waitressing
oh on her first day she was shadowing
somebody
no way crazy yeah man that's cool how
long you guys been together
since 2006 marriage oh in 2013
marriage 2014 good [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] awesome how long was she still
working at the laugh factory
or does she stall no she don't work
through no more she start working there
and like
909 or 11 009 008 i think yeah that's
[ __ ] awesome
that's what an organic-ass place to meet
and [ __ ]
seriously i mean yeah like doesn't get
much more that's a good story i'm not
micro girl in my space
yeah and um and during last comic
standing uh when um
we had to every every time i was
competing at the comedians
we would have to write down our
three-minute set verbatim
on paper oh god and then like the the
the unfunny nbc lawyer will read it bro
and then he'll like scratch out jokes
that are not proper for nbc
and then he'll give you suggestions on
how to say it better
which is weird because you're a lawyer
you are not funny
yeah you all you know are you know how
to scratch out
lost stuff you don't know how to write a
joke
so uh one of the comedians um he's on um
the daily report
a daily i guess the daily show roy woods
he had a joke about wendy's and they
told him you can't say wendy's because
that's
one of our sponsors so the guy said this
wow
we thought you should not say wendy's
but
you should say fast food joint
so just change the joke too i was eating
at a fast food joint
weird and then you see the punchline
so i was like how can he just get rid of
that
gets rid of the whole joke then yeah so
wait this is last comic standing you're
competing with your set and they're
switching up your set yeah every time
every time
but i will write the joke so good that
they don't have to change it bro then i
would just change it up yeah that's
firm hold on did they tell you they were
going to do that or you had no idea
they're going
gonna tell you because i had a couple of
jokes that they wanted to change
that were kind of hardcore like i had a
joke when i say that cops always show up
at the wrong time
they always show up when i'm choking her
that's good but i get why it's getting
good i understand that's a good one
should i shut up earlier
when she called my mom when she slapped
my mom you know
would you call my mom a wet bag what
were the cops then
just the red pen just like yeah yeah red
so you one last comic standing and then
everything's just and then you then you
did your movie
so i did my movie first then i won last
comic standing wonderful
accomplished and then you did a netflix
special right yeah i did a netflix
special
in um and yeah the two nerf like special
i did it in santa ana california
that's that's the third one and a
spanish one
yeah the observatory really in english
and spanish
yeah man that's a good idea i was
watching a bunch of mexican comedians
you know
getting comedy specials on netflix from
mexico
and then comedy central giving away
mexican comedians
special in mexico which is cool but hey
[ __ ] we got mascaras here in
america too
how about giving us some [ __ ] we've been
here for years
[Laughter]
you know so we so we felt like um they
forgot about us
so i said [ __ ] this man i'm gonna
produce my own show so i put my
my own money together my wife and i put
our own money together
and we shot our own special and san jose
improv
and then we sold it to hbo for triple
the money nice
[ __ ] by yourself own that [ __ ]
why did you do that i did that [ __ ] in
2000
2000 i'm 13 or 14 2015
probably or 16. before people were doing
that right yeah i shot my own special
i paid for it and then my agent he sold
it to hbo
and then um hbo had a run with it for
two years
then after it was over i took the
special back
i own it and then i'm gonna try i'm
netflix so this special no nobody's
there no it's not
nobody can find it you know it's not
it's not anywhere because i own it
wow yeah that's sick but you could you
could package it with your next one
say yeah i'll license you this whole one
with the next one too yeah
so my wife she um produced that one and
she oh [ __ ] yeah so the second special
the one the spanish one i did and the
english one
that one was with with um netflix
they gave me a deal bro because they saw
the last one nice they know this can
know how to do specials
let's see what he can do with our money
beautiful so they give me like a bunch
of money
to um shoot two specials
so i i try to go as cheap as i can to
shoot them both
save their money save money and um
we shot it we made money off of it and
now it's on netflix
it's called um bad decisions
in english and in uh mala decisions and
in spanish
that's on netflix right now yeah cause i
already had the english one ready when i
got the
netflix deal but then i told them you
know i'm going to do too special english
and spanish at the same time
can you speak spanish see
but not well so i told them yeah i lied
so i i had a show at the comedy store in
spanish
and they went to go see me but i didn't
know they were going to be there
and they didn't like it no they were
going to just shut the door down on a
spanish one right there and they said no
no you ain't ready
so that i instead of crying and saying
[ __ ] these [ __ ]
and i said okay man tell them um next
time they want to see me i'll be ready
so i had three months i had like a half
a year
so i started going to mexico bro yeah
started going to juana mexico once twice
a month
oh [ __ ] start doing all spanish shows
when i can because i work friday and
saturday sunday
there's no time in the weekend to doing
a spanish show
because i mean i'm an english comedian
so
i started booking myself and tuesday
tuesday nights wednesday nights
off nights thursdays sundays
and then like i will come home from the
road from doing like
six english shows and then i would the
next day
i would have drive to tijuana and do a
spanish show
i'll go drive to do a show on wednesday
so doing the spanish and then trying to
switch it off
how far into your career was this this
is really this last year
before the pandemic 2019. you're
retraining yourself on how to do
this is this is [ __ ] awesome man
so what i did was i went when i went to
mexico i met a comedian named joel sote
mayor
and he's like a fluent spanish speaker
comedian so him and i i would
i took him on the road with me a couple
of times and he saw my set
he and he recorded on his phone and food
translated the whole thing
wow and then i saw his notes and i
changed it and
he helped me a lot so then i started
going to la casa torres here in silmar
in san fernando like a mexican bar with
four banquet halls
so same i want to do i asked my friend
um my friend um
that runs it and he said yeah bro we'll
do a spanish show for you
so we do a spanish show bro free
free they're all free i never i never
like
i never got paid for the spanish shows
even when they even know when they made
money
like they were paying give me the money
i would just give it to the comedians
that were with me like
the young comics hey bro here's the
money you got divided here's the money
you get divided
so i want to get better bro it's not
about the money
so that place bro was
free right but you got together at five
bro from five o'clock
short story 8 30. people getting [ __ ]
up
right there casa torres and somar from
five to nine
standing room only bro like they were
you couldn't get in bro
you couldn't buy tickets to this place
you could just get there early
i destroyed that [ __ ] bro i did
an hour and 20 minutes in spanish
wow what the [ __ ] and i didn't know us i
was flowing bro
making fun of people and they know they
probably the netflix guy were there
oh nice that he gave us a seat how
random
they give me the special right there bro
you're ready i'm gonna give you the
special
and they gave me the date and they
filmed everything for you
yeah and after that i just started
practicing my shows
still going to mexico to get it perfect
and then i shot it in santa ana
bro everything was ready we're going to
shoot it on a tuesday but then kobe
bryant dies
oh man you know the whole outlay shut
down after that bro
like everybody was sad so um
we're going to shoot the special so we
get to the show on tuesday
and a lot of people are wearing kobe
bryant jerseys to the show
and we have to tell them you can't wear
that [ __ ] because that we're not
we're we don't have a spot we don't have
a licensed team
so they couldn't wear it they were all
bummed out
did you still start you start you should
say man how was that experience like
the first show i felt that they were
like bummed for the second show i came
in
strong bro i came in hot
and the next day i did my spanish one
and the guy the guy from netflix he
heard the first piece he saw the special
because
felipe you did it he told me in spanish
you did it
don't worry it goes we're gonna probably
take this one and show it on netflix
so just have fun in the next one so the
next bet
when i recorded the second the second
special in spanish
because i did two in english so they
could edit both
and make a good one and i did two in
spanish they could edit do a good one or
the same clothes
yeah but the my special in spanish i'm
so proud of it bro because i it really
came out good
i like it but you know when i like it
and then people
some people were saying well we don't
speak spanish venezuela we don't speak
spanish in mexico
yeah that's good but we speak spanish
like that in california
and we speak spanish in texas and we
speak spanish there in new york
says our spanish you don't like it turn
it off yeah
you can't please everybody man can't
believe everybody bro you only need the
people that are willing to appreciate
it's like an australian saying they they
speak
weird english in america or some [ __ ]
yeah no you support the support man
yeah man that's cool that you is that
the first time that
that's been done the first time that
anybody's ever done an english
and a spanish special together on
netflix
but um now people are more people gonna
do them oh tom sagura he's doing it now
yes i did oh spanish special did you
find that you got a lot of new fans off
that
yes i have a lot of people who are like
i want to do a special because i have
fans at your age who love me
but and they all translate the jokes in
spanish to their dads
so now they can watch a special together
nice man you brought them together yeah
yeah
that's cool i [ __ ] with that yeah that's
how josh got so successful on facebook
and youtube and [ __ ] he said because
he's like
like families watch my comments yeah man
you appealed to more
when i did my spanish special in long
beach that's when i started noticing
like
groups of people going out together for
the first time
like though this hardcore thug bro was
like his whole from long beach
his head lb tattoo in the back of his
head
he brought his dad and his mother and
his grandmother
and his sisters and they were like a
group of 15
and they saw the spanish show and he he
was he telling me
philippe i was so happy he did a show in
spanish because i always tell my father
and
my dad took a day off today to watch
this show and um
we're gonna go buy a 12 pack right now
18 pack we're going to get [ __ ] up at
the house and just
talk about your show and uh man i never
done it with my parents and we never
went out together
we never did this before he could tell
like
he didn't want it to end you know that
feeling of course feeling you have
you been you had with your father your
mom
he didn't want it to end so they were
going to go [ __ ] watch netflix
special and
drink some beers and have a good time
that's [ __ ] yeah man
that's what it's all for that's what
it's all about right i mean that's the
point i never chewed my grandpa he
he speaks broken english my grandma's
like says some [ __ ] in spanish
they never taught me you know i mean
because i grew up my mom so like that
feeling i've never had that before
never chill with my grandpa anywhere
else ever nothing
because the translation is so [ __ ] he
just gets frustrated with me and [ __ ]
so i get that a lot like you know if
anybody saw the special in english but
then i started spanish
then i saw my mom and we both loved it
but i really like the spanish
spanish so better nice it was more
personal to me
that what they tell me did you feel
really confident in it by the time you
did i did
i did man i really felt comfortable nice
the thing i love about this the most is
the fact that you're already
seized and established and you go no i'm
gonna go practice
i'm gonna practice on something i'm not
comfortable with you and i started at
the bottom bro like i didn't want to be
like that comedian that
goes into a room and just started saying
that he put me up next
he started bumping a lot of young comics
i actually there was a comedian named
patty and um
her name patricia her her instagram is
soy tu puta madre she was headlining
a solo show at the um
the greek palace in san diego it's
called um
it's a comedy club in um san diego
i can't think of it right now i need a
real name but the greek
the greek palace and um
she was headlining on a sunday night
solar show
so i called her i emailed her and i
emailed the club and there any way
i could do a five minute set on her show
just open
and she said yeah it'd be an honor okay
so go
to the brew and do five minutes and i
killed in five minutes
i was happy like like a new comedian
going over his jokes
listening hoping again
i felt like the first time i did comedy
i feel excited you know like i want to
do this more
so i kept going there every week and
then finally um
i put up my own comedy show in spanish
with a bunch of comedians
and i gave them all the money and then i
started doing my own show by myself
doing a whole hour there
and as i started practicing and i got
comfortable
that's awesome man it's inspiring as
[ __ ] to be like
like i said to be so in it already in
this practice like you said you didn't
use anybody to bump it
you just waited and waited for your spot
yeah man luckily this happened before
the pandemic
so pandemic starts in march
after i shot my special so um
my my special um bad decisions
aired on netflix in september
of the pandemic wow so i didn't go to i
i was supposed to start going on tour
right after my special so that was
delayed so i have a new tour
that we're starting in a couple of
months probably in august
how many tour dates do you usually do on
30 oh wow 30
different cities or 20 probably this
year
because of pandemic but yeah man must
are starting my tour it's going to be
the um felipe as far as the unmasked
tour unmasked where can they find like
get tickets or philippeworld.com
felipesworld.com i'm coming to viselia
napa valley monterey salinas
vicelia san diego
i'm coming to porter no no no no
portland
nice are you doing the west coast yes
i'm coming to fort myers
what's that off the hook comedy club in
fort myers where's that at
fort myers florida oh florida so you are
gonna go to the east coast
yeah nice nice do you ever go to
international since you're doing spanish
you're gonna go to mexico
not yet but hopefully man things happen
maybe i could go open up for thomas the
girl in mexico
sick good thing you got a good thing
cooking man that's great
so that's my my web page right there and
how about
world.com june 26th i'll be at colusa
casino in in sacramento july 2nd i'll be
in
royalsford pennsylvania
july 9th through the 11th tempe arizona
july 23rd to the 25th
addison improv july 30 to the
first san jose improv oh you are in
australia
august 5th through the 8th
oxnard august 12th through the 18th
august 12th to the
15th and then pittsburgh california
august 20-22
naples florida off the hill comedy club
and so on people
wow how do you what do you do on your
downtime man you are gone like a rock
star
on the road that long well when i'm at
home i
i take my grandson to school in the
morning and i pick him up
and i go swimming with him see you get
that whole new life you made it sir
yeah it's a whole new lifestyle that's
great you direct
oh man that's he does comedy what
thursday friday saturday
comes home to his grandson and chat yeah
i love it
congratulations congratulations man yeah
man thanks
okay so felipe's co and that starts when
june 20. oh
soon a couple of days california
okay all sold out already okay well guys
go go
we're on the second show man on the 26th
you added a second show yeah i'll be
there with a guy named larry bubbles
brown very funny he opens up for dana
carvey
dave attell he opens up he has opened up
for louis ck he opened up a lot of
people
and um i have bush escobar from
northern california and rodrigo torres
from the what's up full podcast nice oh
so please tell us where can everybody
find your podcast check out my podcast
on spotify it's called the what's up
full podcast
we have over 300 episodes wow
from blood and blood out how was that
bro we didn't talk about blood and blood
out for [ __ ] hour and a half that's
great
that's all i wanted to do but the one
thing i'm asking but yo why'd you hit
your chest so hard when you did that
[ __ ]
right when he comes off the he punched
himself in the [ __ ] chest
damn 300 episodes wow good job how long
how long's am going
i don't know we started i mean five
years ago i think
wow 344 episodes man
it's goals and um well i interviewed um
dave chappelle's partner on my show neil
brandon yeah
talk about what happened when chappelle
left over season three lost
yes and then i talked i interviewed um
gilbert
gio carrillo the guy who cut the night
stalker
really the guy from the netflix special
and the guy that caught the nights are
you talking about the detective the
detective yeah i interviewed him before
his netflix special so you got all the
details yeah
everything on my podcast you can learn
more about richard ramirez
i also interviewed a guy who i met
he was felipe i voted for you when when
i was in prison
wait a minute you voted me when i was
prison yeah philippe i was serving a
house i was serving uh 25 years to life
and i got out on the innis innocence
program
because i didn't do it wow so him and i
became friends and
i interviewed a podcast and i found out
that um he was accused of uh he was
wrongfully
accused of a murder in when he was like
when he was 18 19 years old and then
25 years later he comes out of free man
25 years they let him yeah he was he
didn't do it it was
the the guy who said who pointed
him out and said he did it he said that
um listen man when i pointed him out
i was pressured by the by the arresting
officers
they weren't going to close this case so
bad and i just pointed him out
i'm so sorry i could i could have
pointed out anybody but i pointed you
out
how do you pay somebody back for that
yeah he sued bro you got 10 million
10 million is great but [ __ ] that dude
yeah and and let me tell you man
um her name is frank carrillo and
he um the guy is so positive bro you
would think that
like i could never do that come on i'll
be angry man bro i probably won't even
make it to the innocence program because
i'm probably kill somebody and i'll die
in there
this guy um no tattoos not that it
matters
but he has no tattoos not bitter
like you know he's not one of the guy
you know [ __ ] the guys who arrested me
you know yeah
he went back to school he did everything
he wanted to do he went back to school
he couldn't graduate from college he ran
for
city commissioner of his town and he's
doing good things bro
he's a positive guy a very positive guy
it's a great story and you just met him
randomly randomly bro
on the streets and he was telling us it
was funny because
before the particle he was telling me
that no felipe like
there were some people that are watching
you on television and then they were
yeah loud
number five number five so good now what
does that mean because
you were number five one day so we had
to call a number
and press five to vote for you
yeah support like that that's great so
you out everyone all walks of life
people at home are watching
people in prison or voting damn i met a
guy that was
that was a fireman for sacramento
and he told me that he got in trouble
because um
he automatically dialed he he
automatically um
dialed um the winning the the number to
vote for me
to every city employee bro oh
good use connections like that that's
support
that's better than any flyer you could
ever ask i don't know what those
comedians have on that but i don't think
they do
and what really helped me was without
when they were showing last comic
standing on channel 4 nbc
they interviewed me and they asked me
felipe if you went 250 000
what do you do with that money the other
comedians were saying i'll buy a house
i'm going to buy a car i'm going to buy
this and i and i the first thing that
came out my audience would think about
it i said you know what man
if i win i'm going to donate some of my
proceeds to
father greg boyle from humble industry
because they want to help me
get here homeware industry that's a
building over here down here yeah that's
father greg boyle
he's the one that helped me out with all
the crackhead and put me in rehab
really yeah oh the two dudes that walked
in you said
what the two dudes that walked in and
called your oh you're talking about
you didn't talk about this earlier you
said two of the og's or the big homies
came in
and cleaned you in that crack head up
the guy that you met remember he said he
called your wife or something
well that was that was after without
doing stand-up comedy oh that's not them
no this before when i was
when i was in my 20s oh first ever
gotcha first over he he probably boyle
helped me
and i um i got cleaned up for like 10
years so what what is homeboy industries
what is i see in the building
homeboy industry is a place where they
help people that
come out of prison and they can't help
jobs so
father greg helps them get jobs helps
them get skills
so most of these guys come out of prison
and father gray helps some get jobs all
over the country
really that's i had no idea what it was
when father greg first started
um he would go to a job and go listen
man
can you hire these guys no we can't
we can't afford it okay how about this
i'll pay them i'll pay them a minimum
wage to work at your job
but don't tell them that i'm paying them
but let them work there and get a scale
and if they get good at it maybe you
could hire one that's about how he
started
so five guys will work there and they'll
only hire one
so they'll take and then but father gray
was paying them the whole time
he's really trying to help man he'll pay
him out of his pocket to work there
was he an ex-inmate or something father
grace the priest
oh that's why oh father greg boyle and
it's just called homeboy industries yeah
he's like you're the catholic you're the
priest
wow i've never heard he saved all these
kids while these kids were in prison
that guaranteed to the left his name is
william
the guy to the right the asian guy named
hong
his family escaped the viet cong bro
from vietnam his whole his real father
he was killed in vietnam during the war
but he came
here as a three-year-old i grew up with
that kid
and the one over there to the left oh my
god
see the guy right there that guy right
there with the that's william see the
guy back there
yeah that guy just got out he
i don't want to say his name but i'll
stay off off the off here
he grew up in my neighborhood bro he got
locked up in 1979 he just got a whoa
yeah he got he got locked up when he was
no the kind of other guy the older man
on the left
[Music]
yes he just got out bro he
shot at a lapd helicopter when we were
little kids
oh wow he was like a 19 20 year old kid
19 year old 18 year old kid
and like he was being chased and he sh
she was crazy
he just got out but like where is this
guy going to get help bro like
we had no resume everything that
happened in life happened when he was in
prison
computers cassettes you know whatever
man atari nintendo the internet you know
what i mean
his whole life passing by but without
father greg boyle
this guy has no chance of you know if
anything man
that's amazing he's the one that helped
you out he's the one he's the one to
help me out
so when i was on nbc i said i was gonna
do your money
i'm gonna donate today bro i wanna
donate to him how about all these guys
so every year i donate money so that's
amazing what a cause a cause that
actually you could see the result and
not just that you know like
um he saw the other program like there's
a thing called impacto
and it's like um the only women's
shelters you know you know when a woman
gets old you know like 70 or something
he has nowhere to go you know
you know her family's gone so there's a
place
called impacto and they help um they
have the older women now like a
homeless shelter for senior citizen
women wow
yeah this man's just radiating
positivity out here
yeah man father great boy he was he's a
real g
bro like i remember when um when he was
like when he was um
back in the 80s during the salvadorian
war he was over there
helping and he got caught up brought by
the gorillas
and he found out who he was bro they
blindfolded him
took him back to the city and released
him oh because i knew he was that you
know
he was the man bro wow a lot of a lot of
people
have been here he has also um helped
here baptize also a lot of people in
juvenile hall kids who were not baptized
he had baptized them
so he's a god a godfather to a lot of
kids
a lot of kids you know um got good jobs
from him you know a lot of kids you know
um i know like one girl that
grew up in the same neighborhood she's
like a assistant director for a major
um production company that makes
commercials
yeah so yeah he's a good guy that's
amazing man thank you for getting that
story out i had no idea what that was
yeah i've had him on a podcast too so if
you haven't listened to the podcast
really
father greg boyle on the what's up
foreign
that's great thank you for that i didn't
know that i see i see the building all
the time when it comes downtown
nice man well i know building you look
at it's a cafe they own a cafe
yeah i thought it was a restaurant and
then it looks like they sell a glove
like there's a restaurant
it's a restaurant they make their other
food their other bakery
tortillas it's all made by homeboy yeah
i had no idea what that i
was i was like was that no fear with a
[ __ ] no fear building what was this
because i just you know what i mean like
i have no idea what it was
can't believe the guy got out crazy huh
homeboy industry shark tank
yeah i thought i had seen them on shark
tank that's a great that's a great cause
man especially you can see it happen
well i know we've been here for a minute
yeah man i want to i want to
thank you for coming thanks for having
me bro thank you so much thank you for
sharing your stories thank you for
thank you for talking to me and marty
for this long it's been it's been like
all closer to over two hours
yeah yeah for sure hell yeah really
what's up
if you want to follow me man i'm felipe
esparza comedian on instagram or
funny felipe funny philippe on twitter
or just philippistworld.com man
i hope um you guys like the interview
man do you want to say i'm not
bragging about anything man and um
and i changed my life you know and um
it takes it's very hard man if you're
struggling out there and
call father greg man call somebody get
help
in no way just for you in no way do we
do you sound like you're bragging at all
all right at all so don't don't think
that not in any way
i'm not glorifying none of that no no
you're good man thank you so much i
appreciate it
so felipesworld.com yes felipe.com
instagram felipe as far as a comedian
and you said funnyfully pay on twitter
yeah if you want to watch me acting i'm
in a movie with paulie shore called
oh [ __ ] the guest house i'm in a movie
with um jimmy yo yang
and cedric the entertainer is called the
opening act
so we should just imbd this yes right
steve byrne made that right
the guest house or the opening act or no
steve burns yeah i mean that one he
steve burn director he actually put me
to movie at the cab driver
good [ __ ] see as a kid man when you look
at these things late night like
also nbc superstore i played cody so
oh the superstar the last season my
homies are [ __ ] addicted to that show
you talking about
where it's just a grocery store yeah
good [ __ ] man that's
great yeah i mean that one guest house i
mean that one i pay a priest
father jeff that's amazing
man that's great it's like it's
accomplishment man mexican comedian
now you having to move and you're in the
movies now see that that right there
right
see right there that's the movie i did
i'm not like that no more
wait that's not you yeah with no beard
it's your last crazy yeah it's me right
there that's you
that doesn't look like you at all i
wouldn't have guessed it at all
yeah buddy what please pop that picture
up on the screen when we when you edit
this marty
because that don't look like you in any
way shape or form
what i know i look like selena's killer
oh that's [ __ ] up i want to talk to my
parents
or my mother all right let's get out of
here thank you so much for uh hanging
out
what's up fool thank you so much for
having me guys uh thank you so much for
watching have a dope ass day
this has been a fleet-based barza all
right whoo
that was fun thank you for having me
thank you so much man
[Music]
perfect
[Music]